[Musique]
je voulais m'exprimer avant la première
question parce que je sais qu'il y a eu
pas mal de questions sur Pourquoi je
parlais pas déjà tous les journalistes
ils sont là c'était rien de personnel
j'avais rien contre les journalistes
rien contre les gens c'est juste que je
sais que j'avais besoin de j'ai toujours
ce besoin de me concentrer sur ma
compétition et je sais que quand je veux
me concentrer sur quelque chose j'ai
besoin de le faire à 100% et j'ai appris
un peu que la Fédération elle allait
avoir une amende donc je m'engage à la
payer personnellement il faut pas que la
fédération est paye une décision qui est
personnelle